so let's think about all of the costs of
an education so the first thing that
most people think about is the actual
tuition that you would pay if you go to
a standard four-year College it could be
tens of thousands of dollars a year if
you go to a community college or you go
to a State University it could be a good
bit less with something to think about
and there's other forms of what I would
consider education things like
apprenticeships uh co-op programs where
you might even be able to make a little
bit yourself I guess you could consider
that negative tuition but that's the
first thing it's just how much are you
going to pay for someone to help train
you and for someone to help educate you
the next cost and I'll try to go roughly
in order are probably things that you're
going to need to live wherever you are
getting educated and I know you might be
thinking well I'm gonna have to live
someplace regardless I'm gonna have to
find food I'm going to have to uh have a
place to stay but if you decide to go to
college let's say in a more expensive
city then those expenses could be a lot
more and also certain colleges and
universities have certain rules about
where you are aren't allowed to stay or
you might want to just stay on campus
which might have certain costs with it
so I would definitely consider what's
often called room and board which is uh
where do you live and how are you
getting your food to be a pretty
substantial cost
another cost and I'm trying to once
again go in order of of magnitude of
cost is the opportunity cost what else
could you be doing with that time that
you're putting into that education you
could be getting some type of other job
so there is the opportunity cost of lost
income when you go get an education
especially when you think about things
like graduate school you could be out in
the job market there earning money and
then beyond that there's all sorts of uh
smaller expenses but expenses that still
can add up I definitely had sticker
shock when I went to college and I had
to and I saw how much textbooks cost and
this was uh about 25 years ago almost 30
years ago yeah I'm getting old but they
can easily cost hundreds of dollars I
remember I was trying I always tried to
get see if I could check it out of the
library or share a textbook with a
friend to avoid some of that expenses I
know now there there's some rental
textbooks and digital textbooks and open
source textbooks which might hopefully
help with that cost but that could be a
really a significant expense things like
textbooks or lab materials or all of
these other things that might not be
included in tuition and then on top of
that once again you're going to want to
do all the things that any reasonable
person would want to do when they're
living which is not just have a place to
stay and have food but maybe
entertainment some travel and that could
change dramatically if let's say you are
going to go to college in a different
city than where you live and you're
going to travel back and forth maybe on
a plane that can get reasonably
expensive and then obviously
entertainment and travel in a in a
bigger city and say New York is going to
cost a lot more than if you live in a in
a small town or decide to go to college
in a small town so that's the the the I
would say the space of all of the places
where you could spend your money but I
want to really make sure that this
doesn't scare you because when when you
oftentimes just add all of those
together it can be tens of thousands of
dollars a year in some cases you can
even approach you know the high AI you
know approaching six figures in a given
year but you really don't know what your
costs are going to be until you apply
and you figure out what kind of a
financial aid package you get many of
what you would call the the sticker
price of a lot of universities is is
what they would charge someone who's not
coming in with a scholarship who's
getting no financial aid so these are
usually going to be more affluent people
are going to usually have to pay those
costs but if you come from a less
well-heeled family and those numbers
look scary to you it actually turns out
that sometimes some of the more
expensive universities are the more
generous ones with financial aid I'll
just use myself as an example the
college I wanted to go to when I was in
high school at the time this was in the
90s it cost even then with room and
board and everything it was over thirty
thousand dollars a year which is more
than twice what my mom was making that
year so I was like there's no way I'm
going to be able to do it but my sister
went to a similar type of school that
had similar type of tuition and she got
significant financial aid because my
mother did not make a lot of money we
were on free reduced lunch when I was in
high school
they saw that and and it was a pretty
good uh my mom's contribution even
though the sticker price was you know 30
something thousand dollars my mom's
contribution was something like fifteen
hundred dollars a year and then I had uh
I I did accumulate some debt so it's
still you know I accumulated about
thirty thousand dollars in debt over
four years
which is still a lot better than it
could have been over a hundred thousand
dollars uh but you still have to be
careful even with with that uh to to
make sure that you're going into
something that you feel confident you'll
be able to be employed it's something
that you'll enjoy being employed in uh
and something that you can really put
the effort in to get those jobs so that
you're in a position to pay back the
debt and the investment in your
education pays off but I encourage you
uh you know look at the Spectrum one be
aware of the costs be aware of what the
different outcomes would be and then
think about okay do I want to live in a
big city small town there might be cost
implications there do I want to go to a
private school do I want to go to a
State University do I want to spend
maybe two years at a community college
and then transfer these are all
potential options that affect the cost
equation but they also have other
trade-offs as well so it's more nuanced
than you think but I think especially if
you come from a lower income household
there's probably more options than you
realize in many cases you should at
least try to apply for some of these uh
these more aspirational schools if if
that's interesting to you and see what
they offer you you might be surprised